justin here with a gamespot news update
nvidia has just announced the gtx titan
z a new graphics card with the modest
price tag of three thousand dollars as
Nvidia's CEO puts it if you're in
desperate need of a supercomputer that
you need to fit under your desk we have
just the card for you the nvidia geforce
gtx titan z is built around to Kepler
GPUs and 12 gigabytes of dedicated frame
buffer memory with two gk110 chips the
titans e is powered by a total of 5760
processing cores nvidia says it's Titans
e GPU is different than other dual GPU
cards because its GPUs are tuned to run
at the same clock speed meaning that
neither GPU will face a performance
bottleneck all that power is delivered
in a card that is cool and quiet
according to nvidia the card is
physically architectured to minimize
turbulence and improve acoustic quality
if you've got the money to spend and you
want to try to put together a quad sli
set up with these new Titans ease go
ahead and send us some pics at News at
gamespot com no dirty ones